that playoff run 2018 the saints avoided
being upset at home by the philadelphia
eagles only the next week to have one of
the worst calls of all time go against
them
and lose to the rams drew brees has been
chipping away
chipping away trying to get back to a
super bowl he's now reportedly going to
get a
second opinion to determine whether he
should go
on injured reserve this comes down to
how much time is he going to miss
because if they put on my ninja preserve
he misses a minimum of three weeks
that's the 2020
covid glitch in the ir rules that allows
anyone for any reason to be put on ninja
reserve for three weeks so
either hold them on the roster or you
put them on ir and
any time shireen an nfl player
gets a second opinion that means they
didn't like
the first opinion that they got and it
tells me
that the first opinion coming from the
team doctor is
you're out for at least three weeks
we're putting you on into reserve
and drew brees seems to be sufficiently
stubborn
as i would be to say screw that i'm
coming back within three weeks
yeah i i think you know what's been said
within the
organization is the best case scenario
has him out two to three weeks that's
best case but mike this is a serious
injury and when you have a collapsed
lung i mean you have to be careful about
that you don't want to go out there
and and risk your long-term health uh
for football and frankly they need him
for the postseason and they need him to
be healthy for the postseason so they
need to get this thing helped
uh healed up before he gets back out
there and that's gonna be three weeks or
longer i mean let's
face it so i'm gonna be really surprised
if he comes back before three weeks if
they let him come back before three
weeks he will push it i know to come
back
but you know the saints always have a
plan trust in sean payton they were
five-and-oh without drew brees
last year they'll be fine without them
this year i don't know if they'll go 5-0
or however long
that drew brees is out but i think
they'll be okay
drew brees is an ultra-competitive
individual as most
great quarterbacks are it's it's part of
your makeup or you won't become
a great quarterback you're competitive
about everything you don't want
to not play especially when you're in
this back and forth with tom brady for
the all-time
passing touchdown record and you want to
be on the field you want to be in that
fight you want to be leading your team
you think you're the best option
and i think back to last year when he
had the thumb injury every time they
cut to him on the sideline of the game
he's doing the he's doing the
rehab thumb rehab thumb get back sooner
get back sooner now there's not much he
can do to
get back sooner when he's got a rib
injury and a collapse long but
he wants to get back on the field and i
don't fault him for it but i think this
is part of the push and pull
it's part of the five stages of grief
and you're trying to get him to the
point of acceptance and we've seen a
little bit of that in the news over the
past couple of weeks sometimes it takes
a while to get out of the anger
phase i don't know which phase drew
brees is currently in
but hopefully he'll get to acceptance
and yeah
sharing here's my prediction at some
point tomorrow maybe
by the time we're on the air there will
be a report as to who got the bulk of
the first team quarterback reps for the
saints on wednesday the major practice
installation
day when even though sean payton surely
will say
to everyone in the building keep your
damn mouth shut
somebody will will say something to
someone who'll say something to someone
who will eventually say something to
someone who covers the game for a living
and we'll know whether it's jameis
winston whether it's taysom hill
or whether it's a little bit of both
yeah i'm going to be surprised mike if
it's not james
jameis winston simply because he's the
guy who came in
when drew brees got hurt on sunday and
secondly
teddy bridgewater played last year over
taysom hill
and third they really have to change up
their offense so much with taysom hill
at quarterback and maybe that's
something they do a couple games down
the road i don't know
depending on how jameis winston plays i
do know that
taysom hill is going to be a big part of
their offense no matter if he starts or
doesn't start
i expect him to to be out of the bubble
wrap and a huge part of this offense
moving forward but i'm not sure he's
going to be the starting quarterback and
that's completely and totally just a
guess
but i expect jameis wants them to take
the first snap
my only hesitation continues to come
from the officially unofficial depth
chart that every team has on its website
they say it doesn't mean anything
but last year it was brees bridgewater
hill in that order
bridgewater was the next man up this
year it's brees hill
winston in that order and i can
understand why winston would have come
in
during the game because he's the backup
quarterback for the game
hill is the jack of all trades who's
been doing different things at practice
not
practicing to be the backup to drew
brees and there's your depth chart
unofficially official taysom hill is
number two behind drew brees
but the question becomes do you entrust
the full offense to take some hill and
i'm just fascinated by this from a
palace intrigue standpoint because
they gave taysom hill the contract that
has 16 million guaranteed
you're really not using him to that
extent you're not getting your money's
worth dollar for dollar
and if he's ever going to be the
quarterback of this team shireen
why not see what he can do now and if
you're not ready to let
him see what he can do now and let you
find out what he can do now over the guy
who threw 30 interceptions last year
maybe there's a problem we don't know
about
yeah absolutely they paid him the money
for a reason mike they have said
consistently sean payton has said
consistently he is our quarterback of
the future we believe in him we think
he's a quarterback
so if you do you let him play you change
your offense you do what you have to do
to let him play
and maybe it's a thing where they play
both quarterbacks maybe jameis winston
gets some snaps too
and and taysom hill has a has a package
for him
but whatever they do i do think taysom
hill needs to take a lot of snaps at
quarterback i think they need to find
out about him
drew brees is not going to play very
much longer and i
i think all the signs are there we saw
it last year with the five games he
missed
he's gonna miss time this year he is on
his last legs we all know that he's
played much better than i expected him
to play this season i'll say it
but he is on his last legs he is nearing
the end you have to know
if taysom hill is your future jameis
winston's your future or if you need to
go to find a quarterback after this
season
by the way broncos quarterback drew
locke according to nfl media has
bad muscle strains and bruising and is
considered weak to week and i'm a dru
lock fan
i thought he would become that
quarterback that makes people finally
say hey john elway can draft and develop
someone to play the position that he
excelled at but if you can't
be available to your team on a regular
basis she can't be a franchise
quarterback and shereen i get asked all
the time now what about vic fangio what
about drew locke are they in danger at
some point
that spotlight needs to go one level
higher to the person who's making these
decisions
on coaches and quarterbacks and john
elway has one of the greatest gigs in
football right now because he has no
owner who can fire him
and it won't be even relevant until
the trustees who continue to operate the
team
wait until they appoint one of the pat
boland children to take over
but at some point
you've got to have real scrutiny and
accountability if you're john elway and
i think any other
owner any other team any other
circumstance by now i think john elway
would have been in serious trouble if
not at a minimum
on the hot seat hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports